una imponente pared de lava fundida
llega al pueblo de todoque en la palma
arrasa con todo en su camino
a su paso este residente busca los
restos de su casa todo lo que queda es
un solitario trozo de hormigón ahora
petrificado en la roca volcánica
[Música]
no se puede hacer nada
los bomberos sin embargo buscan
soluciones utilizando excavadoras y
barreras de hormigón han tratado de
redirigir el flujo de lava para evitar
que llegue al mar donde podría
reaccionar arrojando gases tóxicos es
una tarea hercúlea contra un enemigo
vulcaniano que ya está en fase de
erupción explosiva la roca fundida aún
no se ha acercado mucho al mar los
bomberos dicen que están librando una
batalla perdida vamos a intentarlo pero
va a ser complicado porque hay
diferentes alturas que vienen detrás y
puede ganar mejor sobrepasen los
parapetos que hemos preparado
mientras tanto los habitantes de la
palma donde el volcán cumbre vieja lleva
en erupción desde el domingo esperan a
pasar los controles policiales para
intentar salvar lo que puedan de sus
casas
esta mujer corre hacia las llamas
lo que podemos perder son solo cosas así
que es malo pero está bien
los gomeros le han dado 15 minutos para
lo que necesita la vallas visibles
de aquí y los tejados del barrio ya
están cubiertos de ceniza volcánica